and we begin this hour with a look at
the Legacy a pioneering athlete and
activist Bill Russell he died yesterday
at the age of 88. Russell is regarded by
many as the greatest champion in the
history of professional team sports he
won 11 NBA titles with the Boston
Celtics including two as a player coach
he was named the League's Most Valuable
Player five times after he retired
Russell continued to coach and he also
broadcasted NBA games for CBS Sports in
2011 President Obama awarded Russell
with the presidential medal of freedom
for his work as an outspoken civil
rights activist the NFL today host and
CBS News special correspondent James
Brown joins us right now he's
interviewed Bill Russell on several
occasions and he knows him JB what's up
how you doing
Nate good morning and good to see you
and let me just add to that first of all
that peace which I believe was the final
time that bill talked certainly at a
network level with you was a sensational
piece because you got to see the real
Bill Russell very candid and honest and
he reflected today meaning when you talk
with him exactly what he had articulated
and he was about when he first came into
the league
JB um Bill Russell was very private as
you know but you knew him what was he
like as a person
I knew him mostly through those in his
inner circle he was very honest very
candid team oriented all the way Nate
and I love the way his colleagues
referred to him he was the big fella in
every way I love what um Heaven's Bill
Bradley the Rhodes scholar who played at
Princeton and of course played with the
New York Knicks he said that Bill
Russell was the smartest NBA player ever
that speaks volumes about him and he was
always about equality and justice
JB the the covers of the papers
obviously talking about Bill Russell New
York Post here Lord of the Rings and
then the New York Times says a
basketball Legacy as rich as his laugh
talk to me about one of your favorite
memories of Bill Russell
well as Nate was uh reading the
introduction uh Bill had a very close
group of friends jarika very defined set
of friends that he loved and was
exceedingly loyal to the last time I
talked with him was up in Boston at a
big event where they had gathered a
bunch of New England Heroes Bill Russell
of course was the star the biggest
literally and figuratively and I wanted
to get on that inner circle because I
knew him mostly through his coach red
our back Sam Jones of course the great
player who just passed not too long ago
a teammate of his Casey Jones my coach
my sophomore year up at Harvard as well
but Bill I asked him I said Bill you've
got a close group of friends suppose you
meet someone that you like a lot and
would want them in that inner circle
what would you do he paused for about 10
seconds jerika and he said well you know
what I guess somebody will just have to
go so
he kept that Circle very tight
that's a great story JB but I want to
talk about his civil rights activism as
Nate pointed out in his obituary he
marched with Dr King he's still tall
with Muhammad Ali during the 1960s
during the Vietnam war draft
controversy can you just explain for us
and put into context the legacy of his
activism
very quiet very passionate but wanted to
see equality for all you didn't hear him
bragging about anything seeking
visibility he just did you've seen that
iconic shot of 1967 when he was there in
Cleveland with all of those iconic
athletes from across the Sports World
they were there to talk to a young then
Cassius Clay to convince him to go into
the army it would be the best thing for
him and I believe Muhammad Ali was about
25 years of age with all of these
seasoned iconic athletes he wound up
convincing them that he was legitimate
in terms of his um anti-war feelings and
not wanting to kill anyone else and they
left out of that meeting universally
unilaterally supporting him because
that's the way he was Bill was was of
course a jokester and I hope this is
understood in the fashion that it was
meant because it was a pretty tense
meeting but Bill at the end said Champ
talking to Muhammad Ali he says I just
have one thing I'd like to get off my
chest and this is my version of it he
says if you could just talk to the
leader of your faith and just ask them
if they could relax the rules on pork
and on barbecue ribs I'll be more
supportive of you JB
um speaking of getting things off of his
chest he was very honest and when I sat
down with him as much as I wanted to
talk about basketball he wanted to talk
about what it was like playing
basketball on the court but more off of
it and he dealt with so much from what
they were writing about him what they
were saying in his face behind his back
even the fans that cheered him on while
he played they looked at him as less
than off the court what was it like for
him at that time being the greatest
athlete on the court but then he had to
deal with so much when he left it
Nate I think that speaks volumes for the
mental tenacity uh certainly with him
being very close with his teammates that
close Inner Circle that I talk with you
about by the way one of them was Bobby
Mitchell uh the first African-American
who played for the Washington football
team a team owned by an owner who said
that he would never have a black play
for him but he had that close group of
brilliant athletes who kept him strong
enabling him to do that because he was a
man first as he indicated to you and a
basketball player later that was
secondary to that but team was very
important to him and that's where he got
his strength which is why that story
that you told or had pulled out of him
in your interview were in the Kentucky
restaurant that he would not eat if his
two black teammates couldn't eat with
him as well
well we do know he left big Footprints
behind and there's so many individuals
that are walking in those steps right
now JB thank you so much I'll see you in
about a month when the football season
starts all right buddy
hey Nate I'm trying to play catch up to
you right now
all right talk to you soon